[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle sébastien martinez
je suis ingénieur et je suis devenu
champion de france de mémoire je suis
bien devenu champion de france de
mémoire avec deux secrets premier secret
c'est de connaître les clés des
techniques les deuxièmes secret c'est
l'entraînement et pourtant hier encore
j'arrivais dans ma cuisine et là je
n'avais plus pourquoi j'étais dans ma
cuisine ça vous aidera sûrement arriver
qu'est ce que j'ai fait j'ai fait demi
tour et là on arrive dans dans mon salon
j'ai vu le canapé et je me suis dit mais
oui c'est du jus d'orange qui me fallait
vous je suis retourné chercher mon jus
d'orange voyez cette mémoire cette
frustration voulait tous déjà vécu et ça
arrive à tout âge on va appeler cette
mémoire cette mémoire de poisson rouge
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'on a tous
en nous par contre on a tous aussi une
autre mémoire où ça il ya toujours des
détails de notre vie qui rentre et qui
veulent plus sortir moi je me rappelle
très bien la première fois que j'ai de
danser la macarena
j'avais un tee shirt rouge avec un troll
dessiné dessus j'en ai rien à faire de
cette information
et pourtant je suis sûr qu'elle va
rester dans mon cerveau jusqu'à la fin
de mes jours
cette mémoire d'éléphant ce qui est
frustrant c'est qu'on a l'impression de
pas la maîtrise et ne pas pouvoir la
libérer lorsqu on a vraiment envie
pascal a en quelque sorte enchaîné est
ce que je vais vous partager c'est une
clé que j'ai découverte qui va permis de
libérer cet éléphant lorsque j'en ai
vraiment envie
et lorsque j'ai commencé lorsque j'étais
étudiant j'avais pas forcément une
mémoire exceptionnelle
j'avais des domaines de prédilection
comme tout le monde en moi dans mon cas
c'était les sciences j'adorais les maths
la physique la rentrée tout seul par
contre tout ce qui était plus parker
comme le français l'anglais l'histoire
impossible et et très vite j'ai
découvert des stratégies et ses
stratégies m'ont permis d'arriver
aujourd'hui à les transmettre
parce qu'aujourd'hui ce qui m'anime
c'est vraiment les transmettre et je les
transmets grâce donc à des conférences à
des formations à des livres mais ce qui
est important
s'il ya une chose à se souvenir c'est
cette clé moi qui a changé vraiment ma
vie c'est que laisser l'imagination
quand je vous dis imagination
redéfinissons un peu le le terme il ya
plusieurs possibilités
première possibilité la définition de
l'imagination c'est c'est une faculté
donc la définition du petit larousse et
la faculté que l'on a à se représenter
dans l'esprit un objet réel ou irréelle
donc c'est vraiment cette faculté que je
vais vous inviter à utiliser ensemble
est d'ailleurs très souvent des
personnes qui me disent mais comment
faire pour voir une bonne mémoire de
culture générale en france on est friand
de sa de culture générale et par exemple
si vous lancez le défi de mémoriser les
capitales des pays du monde
donc 1 à 100 prenons l'albanie et tirana
si on sollicite notre imagination
tirana moi ça me fait penser à quoi
tirana phonétiquement
ça me fait penser avoir un piranha donc
je vais vous laisser imaginer un piranha
dans votre esprit vous avez ce piranha
et maintenant on va le connecter avec la
suite c'est-à-dire l'albanie alors
l'albanie phonétiquement il peut y avoir
le terme bannir way se faire bannir
donc on a ce type piranha voix qui fait
partie d'un clan et il se fait bannir de
ce clan est là vous représentez dans
votre esprit oui ce piranha qui se fait
bannir et laissez vous guider par donc
cette imagination et associer un maximum
de sens
du visuel peut-être il ya une sensation
tactile du chaud du froid
imaginez des sons plus cette information
prendra vie dans votre esprit
dans votre imaginaire et plus elle va
s'ancrer dans votre mémoire maintenant
vous avez compris on va on va continuer
avec d'autres exemples très concrets
on veut continuer sur sur l'imagination
sur la culture générale
l'albanie ça situe donc c'est en europe
c'est à ses frontaliers avec la grèce et
voilà la forme vous nous faire penser à
une carotte tout en longueur et on va
associer donc cette forme à une carotte
et on va l'ajouter dans notre saynètes
dans notre esprit dans notre imaginaire
et dans notre clan avec no 4 qui mangent
une carotte continuons cette aventure
maintenant d'autres personnes me disent
mais comment apprendre du vocabulaire et
apprendre une langue
prenons quelques chose de poétique on
albanais dire je t'aime saisie des
doigts ont bien sûr je ne parle pas de
l'albanais mais pour retenir cette
traduction dont des doigts
tes doigts on va imaginer moi j'imagine
ma chérie oui j'imagine ma chérie et je
suis en train de lui caresser avec deux
doigts
oui le visage tes doigts d dois dire je
t'aime laisser bien ces images venir
dans votre esprit et ça va s'ancrer dans
votre mémoire
on va continuer avec d'autres exemples
toujours dans une langue là cette fois
ci le chinois qui est un peu plus
complexe avec les formes et si vous
voyez cette forme qui veut dire une
personne
cette forme peut vous faire penser à un
chapeau à peut-être à des baguettes ou
peut-être à des jambes et si vous
imaginez les jambes d'une personne avec
toujours dans votre esprit encore une
fois ça s'imprègne allez encore un autre
exemple en en chinois
cette forme qui me fait penser moi à une
fenêtre ou à une échelle ou à une chaise
et si à travers cette fenêtre vous
imaginez un soleil vous avez la
traduction un soleil le jour et vous le
retenait une dernière chose qui est très
frustrante et moi qui étais très
frustant de chez moi c'est retenir le
nom et les visages des personnes
et pareil on peut utiliser encore
l'imaginaire cette clé pour réveiller
cet éléphant et cie je prends donc ce
jeune homme qui s'appelle thomas
personnellement le prénom thomas me fait
penser à une tomate voiliers et sur ce
visage de cette personne prenons un
détail qui nous anime
donc prenons par exemple sa barbe qui
ressort imaginons qu'elle est un peu
rugueuse et il ya une tomate qui glisse
sur cette barbe je vous avais donc cette
association cette image qui se crée
allez encore une dernière est à fond on
se testera ensemble
catherine catherine qui y voyait une
chevelure cette chevelure qui tombe et 4
il me fait penser à un chat oui 4
catherine un chat et on va poser dans
notre esprit un chat sur la tête de
katherine et lorsqu'on imagine ça peut
nous faire rire c'est bien on lancre
allez maintenant testons nous pourvoir
pour revisiter un peu cet imaginaire ces
associations que nous avons créés nous
avions sur une carte de géographie une
forme qui ressemble à une carotte qui
étaient mangées par donc l'albanie après
nous avions cette forme des personnes
très bien après nous avions ce jeune
homme a qu'une tomate thomas très bien
tirana qui était la capitale de
l'albanie
symbole du soleil bravo je t'aime ténois
et catherine en bien évidemment une
subtilité c'est plus ces associations
vous seront personnelle et vous sont
propres plus elles seront puissantes et
du rendre dans votre vie alors demain
lorsque vous retournerez dans la jungle
dans ce zoo d'informations qui vous sont
propulsés vous avez deux choix soit la
facilité et les s'est réveillé ce ce
poisson rouge ou bien réveillé ce
potentiel
cet éléphant qui enchaîné cette mémoire
d'éléphant à ce moment là pensez bien à
sortir votre clé locle et d'imaginaire
et mais attention parce que ce pouvoir
un peu de cette mémoire d'éléphant
il faut bien bien pensé ça vous ouvre
énormément de portes et toutes ces
portes ça à vous de choisir lesquels
vous allez prendre
et quel sens vous allez donner à votre
vie et ce sens je vous laisse imaginer
merci à vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]